It is implemented so that you can feel as if you are a hero and fight various monsters
. For example, a character using a spear specializes in front and rear attacks,
and a character using a Chinese martial arts uses a lot of unique
sidesteps.  Even when swinging the sword, the direction of the feet or the direction of the shoulder is discarded so
that different actions can occur even with the same technique.
It may be difficult to operate at first, but the more you win, the more
you can feel the action that is as good as
the console action.  You can create the best spectacle you've ever seen. Also, you can
build a command post called the central building,
surround it with barricades to defend it, and install defensive tools such as
Hwayoung Tower or New Boat to focus on defense.  You can attack the opponent's position by using it or by using a combat horse, and strategic play using various
siege weapons is possible, such as destroying the enemy's position with the support of cannons from all sides.
Various channel contents that we can do in real life, such as sleeping, hunting and cooking, are all ready for the game, and the
method is very easy
.  It's very low, so the more you start, the easier and more fun the game becomes, and the
deeper you go, the deeper the fun gets. We are
ready to repair life contents.
Various contents are connected again, so you can become rich just by collecting
and fishing.  It is structured so that all the systems are organically fused as if one's own level
rises  In subtitles, such a familiar sound  To get away from evil, I
set up a keyword and followed it, and it was the noir of 3 of
these. To follow the concept of 3 noir, I deliberately reduced the color of the music and set it to
a slightly dark atmosphere.
Black Desert is a game that creates a story.  Because of this,
I went to music that stimulates
emotions like in a
game of power, but there are a lot of restrictions
A
lot of effort has been put into making the game into music that surrounds it as a single weapon.
3 Oceans wider than evil will be updated, and repairs will be added towards a new life type
.
Traders and improvements have been added so you can experience naval battles and rotate  So
you can enjoy vegetarian food, etc.
Along with a new story, a dark elf race that uses attitude will be added
Dark elves will be one of the representative races that divides Sylvia by winding
In addition, the old generation foot and cooperative eternal life are provided as well as content  A higher-level
boss is also being prepared
. In order to become a hero who fights over thermals by starting with something small in that
huge world of the Middle Ages that we only imagined, or to find a new new parent.  In order to get
a horse or to venture into the beautiful terrain like this, each
chair has their own goal and the chairs are enjoying a lot of swordsmanship
.
The fact that a wide scene has built Sword and constantly providing content like this is
one of the goals to meet the elements of the fight.
Since every game's opportunity is different
, we will continue to work hard to satisfy that preference and satisfy the fantasies of losers.
thank you